and minimalists hello everybody welcome
to the minimalist podcast where we
discuss what it means to live a
meaningful life with less my name is
Joshua Fields Milburn I am Ryan
Nicodemus and together we are the
minimalists welcome to episode 156 today
well it's a day before Halloween Ryan
it's gonna be a scary podcast when I say
it's a spooky podcast we're really this
is not very spook Tober ish no we're not
this is not gonna be halloween themed
but we did think it was the perfect
chance for us to talk about fear because
this is the time where kids dress up and
terrorize their neighbors and force them
to hand out candy what is up with that
dude like we it's weird how we love to
scare her so now all of us but a lot of
us like to scare ourselves so it's sort
of that that adrenaline rush right yeah
oh speaking of adrenaline rush okay so I
went mountain biking I think you're
gonna talk about twisters 1995 album of
that name dude that's a great album yeah
top top five so good dude I want
mountain biking on Sunday with Conrad
from from Google and he he took me on
never heard of it what is this Google he
took me on this pretty easy pretty easy
pass dude so we get our bikes out and we
start going up this hill and it just
gradually gets harder and harder and
then we get to this we could do this
stretch it's just like you know it's a
pretty steep climb maybe a half a mile
and Conrad is like 10 years older than
me mm-hmm and he is just breezing up
this hill and I literally like I Pat
there is these there is these kind of
older ladies walking yeah and I passed
them on my bike and then I was going up
this hill and I got like halfway up at
dude and I was just like okay I have
like I have to take a break so instead
of like just sitting there with my bike
you know I start walking my bike up the
hill right and these these older ladies
dude catch up with me here's their like
power walking and then they start
ribbing me like at least I don't have to
carry a bike up the hill and I was like
alright alright ladies like I was like
it's all about the downhill
like you know this is what this is why I
do the same thing with like anything
else like you know snowboarding it's you
know going up the lift is miserable man
it's all about you know getting able to
come down that hill so I get back on and
like I finish out I finish up the hill
and like I did pretty good it was just
like right above my threshold which is
great because it made me force myself to
like you know just push myself a little
bit more than then typically what I
would that's funny because you got the
peloton yeah so on the peloton when
they're like okay we're going into a
climb like I have to ruin the next time
I'm on the peloton I have to remember
what a climb actually is because the
climb that I do in a peloton was nothing
compared to what I was doing on the
actual mountain bike right so so uh you
know it just totally has given me more
motivation to like it on the peloton
more in like you know just just get get
better and she build off that endurance
those muscles that experience yeah so
anyway we finally get to the top of
though uh-huh and we're cruising down
dude we're flying in and and tune in the
next week's podcast to learn what
happened flying down the hill dude in
the trail Forks aha Conrad goes right
and you could easily see how it you know
going right kind of went it just went
around and kind of was like this smooth
this smooth trail left was this great
little jump and dude that's that is what
I love about mountain biking man it's
like there's this 12 year old mentality
that I have and I like I see a jump and
I'm like sweet a sweet jump man I do the
same thing when I snowboard right mm-hm
so I hit this jump perfect dude just
come off of it
it's suit I'm like yeah and as soon as I
get to the other side I thought it was
like a jump and then a down ramp on the
other side huh
it was a jump in a 15-foot drop like no
I swear to god dude so I'm in I'm in
midair dude I mean it's like you know
you got a second or two the terror seven
oh my god so that so it was so slow
motion man like I go over the jump and
I'm like oh no like what have I done
but because well a
I have I have experience with like
four-wheelers and dirt bikes and stuff
so you know not my complete first rodeo
doing a jump on some first time I've
ever attempted anything like that on a
mountain bike yeah but not my first
rodeo as far as you know just experience
with with doing some extreme stuff like
that so you know I it's you know you you
catalog these different things different
experiences and it's when I was in the
middle there all of a sudden I pulled I
was like dude like I mean I didn't
actually think this but was feeling like
okay I know that if I hold on to these
handlebars and I get my ass in that seat
and I hold on as hard as I can
I've got about an 80% chance of land in
this thing and that's exactly what I did
dude like I came up and I literally like
my I started to go head over in like I
just i sat my buck my butt back in and
just like bottomed out my bike dude but
my bikes like Fat Tire it's got nice
suspension on it yeah um thank God for
the awesome bike
cuz it's it really was if it wasn't for
the bike like if it was a huffy I I
would have crushed it
that bike all I could think was is dude
if you can get this bike to break your
fall like it's gonna hurt as little as
possible so I'm not gonna lie to you
when I landed I had my eyes closed man I
just like was just like oh my god I
totally do I landed that thing like
totally rolled out of that man it kind
of rational Noah Conrad was like he was
like yeah like he was just like you know
hooting and hollering and I went up to
him and I was like I was gonna I'm
hooting hollering he was like dude he's
like you know you came over that you
came over that ramp or that that jump
and out for a second I was like oh no
like Ryan's about to get hurt and I've
got to explain to people what his arms
in a sling and he's like but then you
landed it and I just I thought oh man
like I didn't realize Ryan was that
expertise like I didn't realize you were
that experience of a rider I'm like dude
that's the first time I have ever
attempted anything like that he's like
you look like you do the whole time but
you know it's funny man I'll tell you I
had this realization talking with him
about how like first off the mountain
biking in LA is much more aggressive
than
believe it or not well at least in
Missoula I think maybe this is because
there are are more people here and and
because you have more people you have a
certain set of people who get especially
I'm talking about the hill in general
man like the hills are steeper okay like
at the rattlesnake in Missoula mm-hmm
I've like Mariah I went there all the
time with our mountain bikes yeah and
the climbs that we had at the
rattlesnake we're not nearly as tough as
the climbs of what we have in LA right
and I was talking to Conor and I'm like
dude it's crazy like being in LA like
just this one experience with the
mountain biking and has like totally
like up to my game like it is totally I
didn't even realize today I was gonna
learn something but I mean not that I'm
gonna go and try and punch a bunch of
crazy stuff now but I totally feel more
confident with my bike I also know - you
know before I take a jump to know what's
on the other side yeah there's some kind
of metaphor there dude yeah that is the
metaphor it especially with with respect
to fear the way to maybe maybe tamp down
the fear is knowing what's on the other
side or actually better yet they said
another way it's not knowing what's on
the other side it's anticipating what's
on the other side well and you know I I
actually I do feel because I was talking
to Jillian about this from the burger
mano um I was telling she was visiting
bergamont sab and look up their song
forget about tomorrow it's great if
whoever's listened to this look that
song up right now it's awesome anyway
it's in the show notes write right
podcast it'll be in the show notes so I
was talking her about it she was like
she was like we were talking about how
this is a metaphor and when I think
about the times where I've done that
I've done that before it's not the first
time I've done that this is this is like
has helped me to be a little bit more
trepidatious moving forward what do you
mean so Mariah and I went mountain
biking a few weeks ago and I did the
same exact thing except I bailed
instead of landed the jump because it
was I made I might have been able to
land the jump but bailing I knew 100%
certain that I could get out of there
with you know with minimal injury right
so I bailed on the jump but what I'm
trying to get at is before I took you
know whether it was three weeks ago or
what I did just a couple days ago when
hit that jump in my head I knew the risk
like I didn't know like oh this might be
a drop but probably not is what I was
thinking right but I was prepared for
the worst-case scenario and when I hit
that jump it was like Oh yep this is the
worst case this is exactly but I but I
felt confident enough that even if the
worst case scenario happened I would
still be able to bail out in a way that
you know that I wouldn't be seriously
seriously injured so that's my way of
saying is like I did take those jumps
but I was confident enough with my skill
level to where like worst case scenario
I would have bailed or bike would have
breaking my fall and I would have been I
would have been okay so what's the mean
like what what you're saying here and we
can unpack this throughout the rest of
this episode confidence is a way to kill
fear in a way it is it is but
overconfidence can have you looking down
a 15-foot drop yeah overconfidence is
hubris or overconfidence is cockiness
right and it is irrational confidence
and as opposed to rational confidence
yeah so so confidence itself can be
should be grounded in rationality and
reason when we have hubris right that's
when we really get into danger it
doesn't help with the fear in fact it
can create future fears yeah Ivan when I
first learned to ride a bike I was maybe
five or six years old I tried to learn
to ride a bike but it was the neighbor
teenage kids who were so old when I was
you know five or six right they were
basically adults and they let me use
their big mountain bike huffy or
whatever it was and there's like yeah
just ride down this hill and I couldn't
even touch the pedals and oh my god one
time flipped over I saw the scar on my
chin right now my god flipped over
busted my whole face open oh and I
didn't ride a bike again until I was you
know about almost 30 and because like
we're in Maui yeah yeah that's a good
story and it's because like you you you
don't know what's on the other side and
and trusting someone else in that
as a kid I couldn't be blamed but now as
an adult if something like that would
happen I'd have only myself to blame you
you can't just trust other people you
have to know your level of competence
but there are two problems with that
it's quite often we underestimate our
level of competence that prevents us
from doing anything meaningful or we
have that hubris and you say I'm I'm the
king of the world company yeah well I'll
tell you what though man what I had this
realization about Los Angeles whether
its mountain biking or whether it's like
you know these circuit training classes
that dr. Ryan has has taken me to there
is there is it's impossible to do these
things without upping your game so I was
telling Conrad I'm like dude you know
for a boy out of Ohio I'm fit I was like
but I'm not I'm Ohio with it I am NOT la
fit and he was like yeah he's like it's
he goes it's crazy to think man he's
like but when you think about it people
who moved to LA people who moved to New
York like if they're there to be their
best and he was like if you're around a
bunch of people who were trying to be
their best like it forces you to like
push yourself more he's like dude if you
really want to get good a mountain
biking he's like joining a mountain
biking Club and he's like those guys
will definitely motivate you but it's
like I had this I have this new
appreciation for this experience in Los
Angeles dude because moving to Los
Angeles has forced me to up my game you
know not just with mountain biking or
with exercise but even with my attitude
man like I've had to I've had to really
concentrate because it's not it's not
always easy to be super cheery and happy
in Los Angeles because there's just more
people it's a little bit more packed
people are a little bit more stressed
and you know I've talked about it before
about how you know when I first moved
here I felt like I loved LA but la
didn't really love me yeah and yeah
about how you changed that yeah exactly
so so it's like Los Angeles is it's just
really good it's a good place to go to
really help you up your game and I feel
like if I de came here when I was 25
like it would have chewed me up and spit
me out man but at 37 like you know I
feel like I'm making pretty decent
choices and it's it's a great time but
I'm really I'm really grateful for the
experience just
to push myself a little bit further with
with so many different things here man
the two words you just said they're like
really stood out to me well there was
another one you said to appreciation so
maybe maybe one of the ways to conquer
fear is to appreciate the experience
appreciate the discomfort because really
that's what you're talking about whether
you're going out with dr. Ryan Greene
and doing these fitness classes that you
would never do in Ohio or Missoula
I shouldn't say never but we're less
likely to do in those scenarios where it
really pushes your limits not to a point
where it's you're ramping off of a
40-foot cliff like someone you know that
you see YouTube videos of yeah you're
not doing that immediately but you're
going past you're you're way past your
comfort zone before enough that you can
still grow and appreciate that
discomfort right and then the other two
words you use there you talked about the
what do you just say making decisions I
don't know I'm looking at these two good
fine
who aren't it's great we have people we
work with they don't pay attention to
what we're saying god this is
interesting conversation it's really
interesting to you and I I don't know
how a million people a month listen to
this thing I know to me I wouldn't know
I was talking about the the appreciation
appreciating Los Angeles for helping me
it forces me to up my game and in
talking about how you know people who
move to Los Angeles like they are there
to be the best and if I was 25 years old
I don't know if I could have handled
handled Los Angeles like it would've
chewed me up and spit me out yeah but
you you you said something about
decisions here's what we're gonna do
since you guys weren't listening we're
gonna play it back so and hit pause and
we will play it back and then we'll
return to this conversation in a moment
but at 37 like you know I feel like I'm
making pretty decent choices and it's
it's a great time but I'm really I'm
really grateful for the experience just
alright so the two words yeah we're
decent choices we had to go back and
listen to the beginning I would say dude
I wish that like we should do this all
the time with our conversations and
record them so we could go back like
what was that point that you just made
that I really wanted to talk about about
seven podcasts
oh no I mean I think the so we talk
about appreciation and now now let's
talk about decent choices I think
ultimately the way you can make good
choices by continuing to make choices
you're gonna you're going to make
decisions that will end up being
failures that you'll learn from but the
way you make good choices is to make bad
choices at first it's you know I'm
raising a five-year-old who makes better
choices now than she did when she was
two and it's because she continues to
make more and more and more choices and
she'll continue to screw up just like
you and I will continue to screw up but
the way to kill fear is is that
appreciation we talked about sort of
combined with finding ways to make
better choices and and a lot of that has
to do with was simply asking better
questions as opposed to just the the
knee-jerk reaction they're going with
the flow I'm just going to do this
because it's easy easy easy
or even worse I'm gonna do this because
someone else told me to do it like I did
when I first tried to learn to ride a
bike it was a terrible decision to ride
a giant bike down a giant Hill the very
first time I've ever ridden one and so
what do I learn from that I need to make
better choices going forward yeah
especially in a place like this because
like Los Angeles it it has everything
like anything you want I can get
anything I want on my block I mean let
alone Los Angeles student right I mean
it's you have to leave your house yeah
you have so many options it's like you
it's even more important to be able to
make good choices because you have so
many choices to make in this city yeah
before we get into these questions right
a little bit what are you what are you
afraid of what am I afraid talking about
fear today we've got some questions
about fear but what are you everything
man everything I'm afraid of failure
okay I'm afraid of rejection I'm afraid
of not being significant I'm afraid of
people falling out of love with me I'm
afraid of everything dude I mean there's
I'm a you know I know that I come across
as pretty confident but it's like if I
don't have that confidence and I would
just I just you know crawl in a ball and
like you know just hide from society
yes ma'am yeah cuz that that's the
alternative and it's not a pretty
alternative yeah it's not a meaningful
alternative no it's not one that you'll
find purpose or joy in either you might
find momentary pacification are
momentary comfort or maybe long-term
comfort but that's often the problem
Comfort is the place where we go and die
it's really comfortable in that grave
and and we don't experience experience
life there quite literally but also
figuratively I can't but you know what's
great about any of those fears like when
you can overcome the fear man like it
feels so good like laying in that jump I
mean I don't think I would I wouldn't I
would not hit that same jump again hmm
even though I landed it like I would not
be like oh oh no I can hit that jump
every single time remember our friend
but the feeling of accomplishment was
just like overwhelmingly awesome a
friend leo
bob alta wrote a blog post years ago
called joy fear he made up this new word
yeah and it reminds me what you're
talking about getting to the other side
of that fear is where the accomplishment
the joy comes from quite often and I
think about we took remember earlier
this year we took Ella down to
Disneyland and and also your friend's
daughter what was her name little sweet
yes Zoey
yeah these kids OE it was Ella and then
olia her son yes oh yeah yeah yeah and
the first part we took him to is
Pinocchio come on
that's the first Fred we took him today
were terrified yeah I do like of
Geppetto things they were supposed to be
terrified all right but what I'm
remembering is and you can actually I
think you can still find this on my
personal Instagram it's at Joshua fields
Melbourne yes under the highlights of
Ella there is this photo of its we got
on the log flume what was it called
forget what Splash Mountain
yeah it's flash Mountain and we're and
it's me backs in Ella in this car
together and you could see me I'm up
front like ah and right behind me is
Ella and the look on her face is
perfectly encapsulated with that one
more joy fear is she is on the edge of
terror but also on the edge of elation
yeah
hysteria good extreme joy I'm just
thinking about that picture did that
well and then zoo I assumed it we put a
link to that yeah I think so I Shawn if
you can at least put a link to my
Instagram you can find the highlights
there at the top I believe it was an
Instagram story that I put up I actually
had to buy the photo off of them because
they took it off of the thing and yeah
but anyway and then I zoomed in but you
could really see the joy fear on her
face yeah and what a perfect metaphor in
order to experience the joy you have to
get through that for you had to push
right right against yet it wasn't so
terrifying that it was a terrible
experience well let's keep that in mind
she wanted to write it again yeah it
well during it she was on the edge of
like oh my god I don't know if I want
this right but as she got the other side
it then it was I have to do this again
right I have to do it again all right
well we do have some questions today
hold on what are you scared of oh
nothing you're a bulletproof I'm just
terrified of 90s white rappers because
they will slay your ass yeah I was
thinking you jo-jo Pellegrino and he
will tear you up in a rap metal bone and
in series you know what he's scared of
you well I think my answer to those a
few years ago to be different from from
now I used to be really afraid of being
forgotten mmm whether it was in personal
relationships or in writing or whatever
but it's a such an irrational fear
because if you pan out far enough we're
all gonna be forgotten George
Washington's gonna be forgotten Henry
David Thoreau is going to be forgotten
Seneca is going to be forgotten on a
long enough timeline Jesus and Buddha
and Muhammad are all going to be
forgotten
yeah and so of course I'm going to be
forgotten to write you pan out long
enough what 10,000 years from now
hundred thousand years from now it
doesn't doesn't matter there's some time
frame where all of humanity is going to
be forgotten
so you're not scared anything now well
no what I'm saying is
that helped me sort of put it in
perspective to it to a great extent late
there are rational fears and there are
irrational fears and a lot of my fears
now whenever I come across them I
realize how irrational they are it's the
fear of not being significant it's quite
often that that that is an extension of
what we just what I was just talking
about there but it's often like well I'm
gonna I want to be significant I want to
do something and but really what I'm
saying there is I want to do something
meaningful while I am here yeah it's not
a fear of being forgotten it's not a
fear of not being significant it's a
fear of wasting my time really mm-hmm
and that is a more rational fear because
we all have the same 24 hours in a day
yeah although I had someone I've said
this in the podcast before and I sent me
this great comment
there's this gal on YouTube who I swear
to you I do not read those calm well I
die
well Jessica sent this to me if I go
think oh we have just to read those
comments yes okay I would just turn
comment soft by the way Jess fried has
less fear than all of us yeah in this
room right now but what this comment
this guy said you you guys say there's
we all have 7 24 hours in a day but we
don't and I swear to you she must have
spent two hours crafting the next
several paragraphs of of Mon during and
it was like oh like you're you're
actually proving a point here like we
all do have 24 hours in a day you
haven't have two hours to craft a
didactic right 4,000 word response as
video as opposed to creating something
meaningful the only way that I respond
to people now is by creating as opposed
to commenting yeah it doesn't mean there
isn't a place for commenting but the
best way to comment is to create and and
quite often I find that we comment that
we respond out of fear I'm gonna get you
back so what was so funny better comment
like what was she what was what was
funny was the irony in a home where she
was basically just saying
hey no some of us see I have only 22
hours decided to take two hours out of
my day to craft this comment exactly and
the point is no you get to choose how
and unless you are somehow enslaved then
you are you you get to choose how you
spend your 24 hours today well you know
here's the thing two men with anything
that we talk about anything it is a it
is a you know a majority of what we
speak to so there's always gonna be
exceptions to the rule is what I'm
really trying to get at man so when it
comes to yeah but that goes without
saying exact exactly but it's I'm just I
guess I'm just saying that for my own
benefit because when I see people like
when we say there's no such thing as
good debt and then someone wants to send
us this huge business plan on how you
know they were able to leverage millions
it's like okay great if you're a rich
guy with millions of bucks yeah you're
right yeah and by the way whenever we're
talking about this we're talking about
this for me and you yeah when I say
there's no such thing as good debt for
us man for me there's no such thing as
good that it holds 100% true with you
and I exactly our first question of the
day is from Beatrix in Germany
I am singing for about three years now
and for about the same time I'm
suffering from depression which also got
worse over time right now I'm finally
opening up about it I told my parents
and I told my best friends and I also
got help so that's a good thing but I
recently just met an really awesome guy
and we get along really well and I think
this could be something meaningful
between us but I'm afraid that I would
just make him miserable with my mental
health issues so I don't know if I
should just you know wait until I feel
better and then try to find someone new
or should I talk to him about it and how
would I even bring it up well first off
I'm sorry to hear that you're going
through some issues but I'm really glad
that you're actually going through them
and not trying to get around them yeah
congratulations on just having the
courage to tell your parents your best
friend your your other friends um well
to me that's kind of a sign of what she
should do here how so well if she's
gonna tell her parents and tell her
friends and
best friend yeah I mean if she's looking
at this gentleman like maybe they have a
long-term future together right maybe
this will be her best friend one day
well so so she's got she's got a this
might be the most important person for
her to tell exactly what last week we
had the podcast with Peter Rollins about
love and he talked about what love is he
knows one of my think that's my favorite
part yeah I think I think we both
definitely in our top five yeah if you
haven't listened to it episode 155 love
with Peter Rollins I mean not only did
we bring in a philosopher and and just a
genius but a guy who really understands
love and all of its iterations and in a
way where he's not giving advice
necessarily he's not even giving answers
he's giving perspective
yeah and he's shining a light on what it
means to love and one definition of love
for him was love is giving something you
don't have to someone who doesn't even
want it hmm now for Beatrix the thing
that she doesn't have is the absolute
confidence she doesn't have everything
she's not the perfect human being and so
that fear that anxiety that depression
all of the downsides of humanity is the
thing she doesn't have right now the
person who doesn't want it is yeah this
other person that you want to be with
they would love for you to be perfect I
know I'd love for Rebecca to be perfect
except I actually wouldn't that would
get boring really quickly because Mariah
was perfect then I would just feel bad
for not being perfect exactly right and
so you want to be able to exchange those
those vulnerabilities with this person
now maybe he can't take them maybe he's
not at a position in his life where he
can hand all the things that you're
going through but wouldn't it be better
to know that now instead of two years
from now where you start to reveal all
of these these things that you've been
hiding from him yeah and by the way
aren't you gonna feel really bad hiding
these things from someone you really
care about because that's not love
hiding your most intimate most personal
details now we have to be careful though
we can't dwell on those things either
there's this sort of faux vulnerability
we see it online now I it's weird when
we look at social media
it's one of two extremes in fact I heard
Andrew Schultz from the brilliant idiots
he talked about someone said can you can
you sum up the Internet in one sentence
he said I can sum it up in one word
extremes yeah and what we see on the
internet and on social media in
particular is either perfection you look
at me I climb to the top of the mountain
and I snapped this perfect selfie of my
perfect body at the perfect moment as
the Sun was setting at the perfect time
that's perfection but it's not real yeah
this other side where it's like woe is
me oh I'm having all these problems all
the time I'm showing you everything it's
it's the same symptom it's it's trying
to show people I need your help
oh yeah dude I'm addicted to your
attention just social media posts I'm
having a terrible day don't ask it's
like all you're saying is please ask me
yeah exactly yeah and and you know what
you don't want to do that either what
you want to do is sit down and have a
open and rational conversation with
someone you care about
I've been doing some therapy recently
for some further I've been dealing with
a lot of health problems over the last
two to three years and trying to
untether the the what the therapist
would call psychological residue and
remains from certain traumas whether
it's childhood trauma or it is health
related trauma geographical trauma just
these we have the sort of subconscious
residue that sticks around even after
you've you've healed from the trauma
consciously there's the the subconscious
layer that that tends to stick around
and going through that I've had to have
some really difficult conversations
honest conversations with backs and and
realizing that this is I'm giving her
something that she doesn't want mm-hmm
because I know that she would rather I
just have been healed and be perfect but
I also know that if I'm going through
something she wants to know about it
because she wants to help but sometimes
the best way to help is just to listen
sometimes the best way to help is just
to converse
without without problem-solving
necessarily sometimes it is
problem-solving as well but you might
realize that this person that you're
dealing with this this new this new man
in your life
Beatrix he may not be ready for that but
you better find out now it's better to
find that out now better sooner than
later
yeah because otherwise you're going to
be wasting his time you're gonna be
wasting your time and I guess the other
question that I would ask her Ryan hmm
is what are you really you know I had
two questions actually what are you
afraid of and then what are you really
afraid of I think of our friend Julian
Smith who wrote a book called the flinch
it's a great book and he talks about how
we as humans have developed this well
over over many many millennia we've
developed this ability to flinch if you
were to swing at me right now I'm going
to flinch literally flinch right to
protect myself
the flinch the real flinch is a
protection mechanism yeah and there are
certain flight responses that we have
yeah dude whenever very helpful when I'm
dropping off of a 15-foot cliff yes
there are like responses that had to
kick in or I could have been seriously
injured it's a necessary flinch but when
I you know got down the hill and I
realized that when I hit the ground my
water bottle popped off and it was up on
top of the mountain mm-hmm I was
flinching like oh my water bottle yes oh
just and then I'm like oh I hope someone
finds it and says man there's a really
cool collapsible water bottle yeah and
then they end up using it like I was
able to get over that but it's like we
flinch at dropping on a 15-foot cliff
and I flinch it losing my water bottle
yeah when are when our stock portfolio
goes down 1/10 of 1% in a week you're
like oh no and we flush at these st.
these same things so Sean I put a link
to the flinch
in the show notes and I think that what
we realize is we need to realize is that
there are the appropriate flinches yeah
that are helping us there are the
appropriate fears that protect us but
however most of the fears 99% of the the
flinches are ourself manufac
sure and and we can as you let go of the
the water bottle we can let go of these
spheres of these flinches well it's
funny man because you know the the fear
of you know falling on the the the
flinch you know falling on my clever you
know coming off the other side of that
ramp the flinch of losing the water
bottle when I think about the anxiety
that was induced it's actually equal
amounts of anxiety with the falling off
the cliff it's like an anxiety like I
can except like oh yes I'm supposed to
be anxious about that yes I've got to
react to this right now we're with the
water bottle I've got to look at that
and say I know I feel really anxious
right now but is this something that I
really need to like perpetuate is this
something that I need to sit here and
dig my heels in and keep feeling angst
about it right but it's it isn't as
useful it is interesting I like it's the
same feeling and like it is up to us to
be deliberate with where we're putting
our attention with those with those
different feelings you know they'll a
couple things I wanted to tell Beatrix
here is you know you you want to tell
your your partner now what's going on
because you want someone who can love
you at your best but someone who can
also love you at your worst and what I
mean by that it's not like Beatrix can
just start you know killing puppies and
that her partner should love her well
you can in the thing is I mean Ryan if
you started killing puppies I would I
would love you still but we wouldn't be
friends anymore yeah and you would go
out of your way to help me and things
like that I'd help you kill the problem
yes you're right help me hide the dead
puppies body because course I would but
no but here's here's the thing that was
like there is a limit meaning when
someone is continuously making bad
choices and they are putting themselves
in a situation that they are you know
they are undoubtedly doing it to
themselves whether it's a mental health
issue or an addiction whatever it is I
mean there is a certain limit where
you'd be like Ryan like we cannot be
friends anymore
however you know depression beatrix
that's out of your control like that is
something that you don't have full
control over after you're out your
entire life this problem might poke it's
it's ugly
head out and there's no intros no way of
telling well uh sure there is some
control but she will never have full
control over I totally agree with them
so that so since she will never have
full control over the depression she's
got to make her partner aware of like
hey this is one of my flaws and you know
I'm feeling good right now but this
might this might come out this might
come out later right but we'll never
have full control over anything and that
that's the reality we don't have full
control over all the circumstances that
happen to us some of it's luck some of
us happenstance
some of it is skill some of it is yeah
inborn talent some of it has to do with
the cards we were dealt at birth or the
accident that happened midway through
our life we you pan out far enough and
you realize control is a bit of a a
misnomer right I mean we have decisions
we have those decisions we can make on a
regular basis and it seems to me like
Beatrix's make yeah good decisions right
now exactly the thing I will warn her
about especially with respect to
depression or let's just say sadness
here misery loves company and you have
to be really careful of that something I
have to be careful of whenever I'm
feeling down don't drag the people
around you down as well you you can
communicate what you're going through
without dragging the other person that
you care about through the mud because
that's not loving at all that's the
opposite of love however it tends to be
our our our main objective at the time
we're feeling bad how can everyone else
be happy I remember when I got divorced
dude like driving around and like seeing
people smiling I'm like how dare you how
dare you smile at my marriage just ended
yeah you know the other thing Beatrix is
you don't want to mislead your partner
it's not that you're misleading them
right now but on a long enough timeline
if you don't say something then you are
you're not being yourself and you are
misleading your partner and I wrote down
here how I would have the conversation
personally I only do this because you
know maybe she can't find these words so
I'm just gonna give her a little just a
little sample of what I would say I'd
say yeah I have something very personal
that I'd like to share with you I'm a
bit trepidatious because I'm scared of
being judged because that's that's a
fear I'm scared to be in judgement she's
scared of her partner judging
and leaving her I'm scared of being
judge but I also want to be open with
you because I value our relationship so
much so Beatrix if you can go out of
your way to show your partner how much
you do value this relationship being
open and honest with them is one way but
also making those good decisions that
help help you to control the depression
as much as possible right like if you
wake up feeling sad you can perpetuate
that feeling and continue to do
depressed and you can you know you can
crawl up in a hole and just sit there
and cry all day and it might be very
easy to do and I'm not trying to
mitigate like there is actual clinical
depression but we do have these small
choices that we can make to to kind of
help control it a little bit in Beatrix
if you're doing just the small things
that is that is going out of your way to
show your partner how much you value
that relationship so continuing I would
say you know for the last few years I've
been struggling with depression to be
honest you've been the brightest light
in my life ever since I've struggled
I've been struggling with this and I'm
not sure if this is something you're
willing to support me on but I wanted to
be upfront with you before things got
too serious and like that is a that's a
very and you can edit that however you
want Beatrix I'm just given that as a
tool for you you could not even say
anything like that but but taking that
approach it's being open and honest and
it's it's it's this is a long winded way
of asking your partner partner your
partner would you be willing to support
me through this time yeah and and by the
way make room for them to be open with
you as well absent room for them to say
you know what I would like to but I'm
not able to and that's okay too you have
to respect if they're not able to if
they're not in a place in which they can
do it and that leaves me with one last
thing there is this essay we'll put a
link to this in the show notes it's
called the worst thing that could happen
and I think it's a question that we
often ask but we don't ask the other
side of it yeah risk is terrifying many
of us associate risk with failure
failure with pain yet we're told we must
take plenty of risks to succeed succeed
thus success must be painful right not
necessarily when
comes to challenging our preconceived
notions about risk the common platitude
no question tossed around by
kind-hearted friends and self-help gurus
is what's the worst thing that could
happen and that's one thing I would
challenge her to ask right now what is
the worst thing to happen
truth be told some risks are fairly
benign letting go of your most of your
material possessions asking a cute guy
or girl for his or her phone number
writing the first page of the book
you've always wanted to write what's the
worst thing that could happen likely
nothing at all there's no real risk in
these harmless endeavors
other risks however probably should
scare the hell out of you skydiving
purchasing a home quitting your job
ramping 15 feet I added that part in
here oh I should have taken a picture
that clear I gotta do Conrad as you were
going when Conrad I know were talking
about it cuz like the whole time I'm
like I can't believe I did that he was
like dude you can tell that story
however you want I will totally get your
back on that story he's like it's one of
the most amazing things I've seen yeah
right
and you crashed so so there were some
things that should scare the heck out of
you right the skydiving purchasing a
home quitting your job what's the worst
thing that can happen some pretty awful
things actually death debt and poverty
respectively so so the death could
happen if you skydive so think about
that debt can happen when you purchase a
home sometimes you can be upside down
like I once was when the housing crash
happened so debt and then poverty you
quit your job yeah you might end up poor
or homeless that's it's not something to
be taken lightly
and so you have to think about those
things that doesn't mean you shouldn't
take these risks it means you should
approach each risk with a logic reason
and intuition peer over the edge before
taking your proverbial leap and if it
makes sense then leap because not
leaping can be a much bigger risk mm-hmm
the difference then between the benign
risks and the real risks is that the
latter and the latter possesses
potential
life altering worst-case consequences
while a former possesses virtually no
threat at all when you think about it
though the benign risks can also hold
life-altering consequences if you change
the question what is the best not the
worst but the best thing that can happen
perhaps getting rid of your excess stuff
will free up time money space and give
you the much needed peace of mind that
you've been looking for
perhaps that phone number will lead to a
fulfilling relationship or in Beatrix's
case here perhaps this conversation is
what will really make the relationship
fulfilling and and whole I shouldn't say
whole or complete because it'll never be
truly complete but it will make the
relationship the best version of itself
well do differ partner is a seven on the
what is the test called not the monogram
yeah so if her partners are seven on the
Indian Grimm
I mean he could very well look at this
as an opportunity to be a mentor to her
and to help and to help her absolutely
and maybe maybe this is the opening he's
looking for yeah to say I really want to
help you thank you for giving me this
open aura maybe he says you know what
I'm really out for myself right now I'm
career oriented and I don't have time
for this but then at least you know and
the worst thing that could happen there
might actually end up being the best
thing that could happen LeBron James was
talking about this recently when he I
think was a 2011 when they lost to
Dallas in the semi finals the Heat lost
to Dallas in the semi finals of the NBA
Playoffs and they asked him if it was
like his if that was his biggest failure
and he said no that was my biggest
success hmm because it helped me
understand that I wasn't really fully
committed I wasn't all the way in and
and that helped me win the next several
championships and also go back to
Cleveland and win that championship
which is one of the biggest
accomplishments ever so sometimes those
biggest failures as a moment you walk
away from lead to the the biggest
accomplishments in the future I won't
read the rest of this essay but we'll
put a link to it in the show notes Ryan
how about we give beatrix a copy of our
book everything that remains cool
because there's a chapter in there
specifically where we talk about
vulnerability and a nope
for love and being vulnerable and sort
of some of the lessons that that I
learned with one of my most precious
relationships that I really really
screwed up and I realized I wasn't being
vulnerable but I also learned about
contributing to that relationship in a
way that I needed to but wasn't and so
Sean if you could reach out to Beatrix
in her the audiobook version if you
liked our podcast you'll love the
audiobook version of everything that
remains it's my favorite book that we've
everything we are written or we have the
book book version if you're watching
this on youtube you could see the book
book version here or if you want the
eBook version we'll send that to you as
well it's called everything that remains
- memoir by the minimalists alright our
next question is from Bianca in well the
sheet here says vagina but I bet she's
in Virginia I've no chicks
I've never been to Virginia but it
sounds like heaven
Beatrix Bianca add some good
alliteration man all right let's let's
talk to Bianca in Virginia I believe I
can definitely call myself a minimal so
um even mine a four year old I would
call her one the things she says it was
the fact that she can grasp it at such a
young age and appreciate it so wonderful
and my husband's always supportive um so
I'm really lucky there and we've gotten
rid of so much stuff and as my health is
improved everything just it's great I
love it and that's the way I want to
live my life forever
but recently a lot of my immediate
families my own parents and my in-laws
have really come down on me attacking me
I've been called a bad parent um I've
been called not humble I grew up in
Virginia so I my mom said that she
thought she raised me with more southern
grace and styles and to not accept gifts
and well I tried a decline limit in a
really positive way I'm like oh well
this money could be used elsewhere this
gift could be used elsewhere I'm not
going to find value in it I try to do it
in this respectful way but the older
generation just doesn't get it
and I don't expect them to get it but
because they're very
mean to me about it and I just don't
know what to do at this point I want to
just like cut everyone off but my
husband and daughter and people our age
that you get it but I don't know if
that's the right thing to do man I so
here's the thing I mean of course I'm
going to going to start off by saying
judgment is but a mirror that reflects
the insecurities of the person who's
doing the judging and it's great that
you have this immediate internal support
system your daughter is a minimalist
which is is great
can I borrow her it doesn't it doesn't
sound forced either it sounds like like
her daughter can see the benefits of
giving to another kid or doing something
you know better with their resources
than just having an extra Barbie doll or
something and the most important thing
is your husband your partner in life is
supportive that's amazing and yeah Bravo
to you now you're in a circumstance
where the people on the periphery they
may still be your primary relationships
but but they're probably not even your
close family now is becoming secondary
or tertiary relationships to you because
of the way that you are are being
treated because the way they are
treating you the first thing I'll say to
you is if someone who loves you is being
mean to you they might love you but
their actions don't reflect that kind of
love what and also it also reflects like
the judgment that they have on
themselves yeah so sometimes the people
who are meanest who you love you the
most we did a living room conversation
with Peter Rollins after our podcast
last week gets up on our YouTube channel
right now and the question that we
answered there was why do we fall out of
love we also did a PostScript episode on
on patreon and the question there was
about his love the answer his love all
we really need right and the answer is
it depends what you mean by love
ultimately right like love isn't enough
if if our actions don't show that love
as well because you can love someone and
still be mean to them and it sounds to
me like her family's being mean to her
and I think the tool that you have right
now the leverage that you have right now
and this hurts to say but it's the truth
the leverage you have right now is
distance and your and you're gonna have
to in a way create that distance because
if you had to choose this relationship
all over again if you were able to go
back and pick your parents right now
your parents are being mean it doesn't
mean that they don't love you but
they're treating you a way that isn't
loving ya and the way for you to fix
that is to create a distance to make
room for people who do love you and show
you their love and show you they care
show you their their support now the
thing I'll say Ryan out and tell me if
you agree with me on this I am if they
give you a gift I'm not going to go out
of my way to turn that gift down no well
the worst thing you could do in that
scenario a I'm thinking of the parodic
exaggerated example here if you were to
hand me a gift
I told today's your birthday recording
this on your birthday actually happy
birthday Thanks if I were to bring you a
gift and you're like I hate gifts you
slap that on my hand and walked out of
the room that'd be like the worst thing
you could do right yeah or maybe she
could punch me or something but like
other than physical violence you could
slap the gifts out of my hand walk out
of the room that is how her parents
might be receiving or perceiving her her
rejecting the gift yeah her rejection of
the gift and they might even though
you're not doing that that might be
their perception and so I think one of
the ways that you can get over that if
if if it's just about you receiving the
gift there are two things you can do one
is and you need to take some your you
need to take some responsibility here
yourself Bianca is ask yourself how am i
setting the right expectations with them
yeah six months in advance am i letting
them know that hey I'm not saying don't
get me any gifts don't get my daughter
any gifts but gift us some experiences
gift us consumables here's what we need
setting those expectations and then not
just planting the seed six months in
advance but watering that seed over and
over and over so that by the time they
show up they know both consciously and
subconsciously what you need because
gift-giving is not a love language
adding value is the love language and
what your parents are trying to do here
is they're trying to
a way to add value to her life in the
only way they know how it's not adding
value to your life you can't communicate
to them though hey this doesn't add
value to my life you need to tell them
what does add value to your life and the
other thing that you can do is accept
the gifts they give you and say thank
you very much I really appreciate that
you're trying to add value to my life
and thank you thank you thank you and
then do a better job set in that
expectation going forward yeah
absolutely and once you accept those
gifts they're your gifts you get to do
what you want with them yeah it's funny
like if I gave someone a gift and well
I'll give you a perfect example I I was
in Ireland with this was you know
September of 2016 in Mariah and I had
stayed with John Sweeney who's just got
an incredible story probably the only
John Sweeney and Ohio and he's a great
dude awesome family and when I left like
I was motivated to buy his kids
Christmas gifts
so like Mariah and I we went out of our
way and we took each child and we were
like okay this child is gonna really
appreciate this the shadows really gonna
appreciate that and I we wrapped him up
and because I knew that his kids would
really enjoy unwrapping something sent
from the states and I was fairly certain
when I got them they would be really
really excited about and because I mean
I got we got to know their kids like
individually like I'm on a pretty good
basis so I sent the note to John and I
was like hey man you know I know it's
really weird getting gifts from one of
the minimalists I said but I really
think that these things are gonna add
value to your kids lives if they don't
like feel free to get rid of them
because the thing that would the thing
that would hurt worse than him rejecting
the gift would be him holding on to a
gift making himself miserable just to
not hurt my feelings because I didn't
get them gifts to for them to hold on to
and to say you know look at me I got you
these gifts I gave them the gifts for
them to enjoy and if they don't enjoy
the gifts if they enjoy their life more
without the gifts then I want him to get
rid of those but the one thing that you
we're talking about their job
was support he kept bringing up support
man so if I was Bianca the first thing I
were to start with in this situation is
I would ask myself have I gone way out
of my way to add value to my family's
life Bianca if you have gone out of your
way to add value to your family's life
then then the next question maybe you
need to ask yourself you know have I
gone way out of my way to support them
so if you've gone on your way to add
value if you've gone out of your way to
show support to your family then you've
got to have that talk that I had with my
mom when I first when we first started
the minimalists you've got to go to your
family you got to go to your mom and you
got to say mom I love you so much you
love me don't you she's gonna say of
course I love you mom I want you to be
happy I really want you to be happy and
you want me to be happy too right yeah
of course I want you to be happy well if
you want me to be happy I don't need you
to be a minimalist I don't need you to
stop buying gifts for everyone but I
really need your support and what your
support is going to do is it's gonna
help you and I have a better
relationship and it's going to help me
be happier if they don't support you
after that I totally agree you've got to
create that distance but it is
impossible I love that man I forget what
city we were in but this teenage teenage
girl her mom teenage girl dragged her
mom out to one of our events yeah and
she was like oh you know so nice to meet
you and she was like you know I really
even like my mom really needs your help
and you know she's got all this stuff
and I could tell her mom is like being
polite and not you know kind of arguing
with it like she's just letting her
daughter kind of throw her under the bus
with her stuff yeah and I looked at the
daughter and I said you know what it's
so awesome you brought your mom on here
I said have you gone out of your way to
add value to your mom's life have you
gone out of your way to support her and
she was like oh I do forget to do that
sometimes hmm and her mom was like her
mom was like thank you for saying that
like I could tell but but you know just
just asking that question it kind of
helps us to you know just look in the
mirror a little bit more I think
sometimes we need to look out the window
and say you know what I've gone out of
my way to support that person and
nothing more I can do to you know make
this relationship any better I've really
done when I could exhaust all the
resources I could to make this this
relationship good but I've decided and I
hang out with that person but sometimes
we need to look in the mirror and ask
what have we done we're asking this
person to support us what have we done
how have we gone way out of our way to
support that person but just going back
to what I said
yes Bianca if you've gone out of your
way to add value to your family's life
if you've gone out of your way to
support them and they're not giving it
to you back well that is a that's a
pernicious relationship yeah I mean and
it doesn't matter if it's your mom it
doesn't matter if it's your cousin it
does matter you fret it doesn't matter
whoever you have in your life where it's
a pernicious relationship you dad is
only gonna bring you down it's not gonna
help you you've got to create that
distance and sometimes when you create
the district distance that gives you the
leverage to actually improve the
relationship now you can't change
someone else's expectations and that
that's what she's calling up asking us
right now is how do I change this other
person's expectations you can only
change your own you can set expectations
better and like Ryan said you can
certainly go out of your way to add
value and oh and speaking of you have
some practical gift giving tips we have
a book called essential and it's 150
essays but twelve different chapters
about intentional living one of those
chapters is actually about gift-giving
so Bianca I'd love to send you a copy of
essential it's which chapters I don't
know but there's an entire chapter on
gift-giving here
Podcast Sean if you reach out to Bianca
give her the audiobook version or if you
want the book book version you can see
it here on on YouTube or the eBook
version as well I'll say it to Josh if I
tried to appease every family member and
every friend like I wouldn't have got
much further with you than the
minimalists comm I mean I would have
like stopped there yeah and the reason
why I continued is because I knew I know
who I am
I know what my actions were are I know
what my intentions are were and that is
what gave me the confidence to push
through any insult any any negativity
that was dollars of fear yeah absolutely
but you know this is a very hard
sentence
for me to say but it's the truth we
don't owe our family anything you don't
owe your family anything the only thing
that you could the best thing you do for
your family to support them love them go
out of their way to add value beyond
that you do not owe family anything
family as such is such it's a it's it's
it's a misnomer sometimes people will
say like my my brother for example he
was explaining to me he's like man you
know I feel like we're not close and you
know you you know you've you've got
you're in Montana and Beau and he's just
like you know kind of getting down on me
for like not being close to him and I'm
like well let's I was like let's talk
about how you've treated me how have you
treated me over the last few years oh
that doesn't matter man we're family it
doesn't matter how I treat you I'm like
no no see it does matter absolutely I
was like I have friends who treat me
better than the way you've been treating
me it doesn't matter man those are
friends those are family we're blood man
I said yeah dude but don't you think
even the more so that family should go
out of their way to treat me better than
how my friends treat me and like that at
that hit I'm pretty good mmm because
because family is it does mean something
like it family does mean something me
I'm not trying to undermine how
important family is to me like I have
some family members that I would just
throw myself on the tracks for like I
really really appreciate all my family I
mean at this point like they're all kind
of come full circle and like they're
really really supportive but you know at
the end of the day though like I cannot
forsake my own mission for someone
else's discontent tweet that that's good
don't put that in the minimal Maximus
all right y'all we'd love to hear what
you have to say so if you have a comment
or a tip about fear or any Halloween
costume advice including any advice for
any of our callers today leave us a
voicemail for 0 6 2 1 9 7 8 3 9 you can
also email a voice memo to podcast at
the minimalists comm will air our
favorite comments and tips on a future
episode and stay tuned to the end of
this episode for this week's listener
comments and tips Ryan what time is it
you know it's
it's time for our lightning round where
we answer questions from the social
medias we're on Twitter Facebook and
Instagram at the minimalists during the
lightning round so Ryan and I each do
our best to answer every question with
just a short shareable less than 140
character response we also put the text
to these minimal Maxim's in the show
notes so you can copy and share our
pithy answers on social media if you'd
like and now you can find all of our
quotes in one place thanks to our good
friend Jessica land Williams
over a minimal Maxim's calm all right
our first letting run question is from
Daisy do you have any tips about
conquering the fear of putting your
creative work out in the world I'm
haunted by thoughts like others have
done it better and what if people hate
it well you know what both those answers
are true like yes someone's probably
done it better and yes some people are
gonna hate it yeah it's absolutely true
they here's the thing and I'll give you
my pithy answer here in a second yes
others have probably done a bit better
but they haven't done it how you've done
it yeah
and I remember we first started the
minimalist calm we started the website
and a few months later I realized how
many I only knew of like four or five
minimalist loggers out there all of
which were doing it better than us at
the time for sure because we hadn't done
it yet
so by definition they were doing it
better just because they were doing it
even if they were doing it badly they
were doing it better than us not doing
anything at all right now something done
badly is better than it not being done
at all you can reword that and probably
tweet it podcast Shawn yeah that's but
what I realized once the sort of
blogging star connects with all there
were a thousand different minimalist
bloggers out there and the difference
was you and I had a different
perspective we were these two corporate
guys we were still both in the corporate
world at the time approaching age 30
mm-hmm both of us to turn thirty that
year and we were walking away from this
corporate world but we also had the
skill sets that we developed from this
corporate endeavor that we had gone
through over the last dozen years
working at the same corporation climbing
the corporate ladder learning about
leading people learning about our own
values and what we no longer valued we
also had the person
effective of our childhoods growing up
really poor and and living through
poverty and discontent and substance
abuse and alcoholism and all of these
perspectives were different from these
other people so even if someone's doing
it better they're not going to do it
like you and so my pithy answer for you
Daisy to answer your question is it's
not worth creating if everyone likes it
amen yeah mama always told me if
everyone likes you something's wrong
something's up
yeah - Ryan you oh I'm by the way I got
some stuff from Seth Godin here uh
because she asked about like I print out
these two essays she asked about her
what do I do now and and these to me
were really inspiring we'll put a link
to both of these in the show notes
they're really short this one's called
the daily and Seth Godin writes this is
there something you do every day that
builds an asset for you every single day
something that creates another bit of
intellectual property that belongs to
you something that makes an asset your
own you own more valuable something that
you learn every single day is a lot of
days it's easy to look at the long run
and loll yourself and the skipping a day
now and then now and then but the long
run is made up of short runs yeah man
even if it's not a public asset even if
it's just like a journal it could be a
journal it could be a private blog
it could be a pseudonymous blog you know
and under someone else's name it could
be a podcast it could be a youtube video
series it could be writing a book but
doing it every single day you know I
teach a writing course how to how to
write better org and one of the things I
teach my writing students is building
that habit of writing every single day
but writing crap it's what Anne Lamott
calls the sfd write the crappy first
draft yeah and and set the cfd I got you
and we're trying to cuss less yeah well
I just I haven't done it yet this
episode so otherwise Ella has to come in
at the beginning of episode and say this
podcast has bad word
which I'm totally fine with but uh I
don't have to be gratuitous either
anyway why did I get it out of the way
whe what of what I've learned is that
you have to have that that terrible
force trap in order to create anything
meaningful this book right here in front
of me everything that remains was about
I was over 700 pages and it's bloated
zenith but a lot of it was it was not
700 publishable pages it's 200
publishable pages but you had to get all
the sediment out so you could go panning
for gold yeah and I think that's that's
what's important and so yes other people
are gonna do it better from you some
people are going to hate it and that's
that's good that means you're doing
something meaningful you know you got a
note here I don't know if I've missed
you saying this but you you ever know
that says create to create not to reach
an objective oh yeah yeah this that's
something else you could tweet here
podcast Sean that is so true man because
it's too often the like we have these
expectations with our creations and if
the creation comes to its full and we're
like oh this isn't going to achieve the
result that we expect like that can
paralyze us from putting it out into the
world right and and by the way what
other choice do you have yet you still
have to keep creating after that
otherwise you're just gonna stop
creating yeah I mean I think about one
of my favorite things I did in my 20s I
wrote a novel called as a decade fades
and I don't recommend you read it
necessarily but some of my favorite
writing of my life is in there and some
of them are the worst writing of my life
is in there as well worst published
write writing and there are parts of it
are truly beautiful but I did it and
it's out there and I'm a better person
because I went through that exercise of
many years like four or five years of
writing that thing and and because the
alternative was what to not write it and
not become a better writer in the
process one of the things from Seth
Godin here diving boards the leap at the
swimming pool is obvious indeed ten
steps up the ladder the weight at the
end of the board the moment in between
not diving and diving the leap is clear
we can see it and we can feel it in
day-to-day life we have worked to
eliminate that feeling organizations and
marketers and friends
work hard to have it happen gradually
instead an incremental almost invisible
creep along a slippery slope until the
next thing we know we're in a rut or
bored or ill we've constructed a life
where we rarely leap like a new job and
most of the time we Coast or fade or
increment our way forward it might be
worth investing the effort into turning
some of your decisions back into leaps
and right now daisies at this precipice
and she can either leap and start
creating or you can increment your way
toward nothing and meaningful you can
react you can respond you can comment
you can retweet but that's not where
you're going to get the satisfaction the
joy the value the meaning the creativity
that you desire yeah and then the
difference here between the leap that I
took with that 15 foot cliff and the one
that Daisy is talking about she knows
what's on the other side like she has a
very good idea of what is on the other
side and by the way you can't get hurt
from this leaf right and that's just sit
man it's like and that's that's kind of
a metaphor too it's like you can take
that jump as long as you can clearly see
what that landing is is looking like and
even if I knew what was on the other
side of that jump it's still it's still
a risky jump but having experienced
having good reaction skills being
comfortable with with my skill set I
know that it may be a messy landing but
I'm gonna land one more thing for Daisy
before you get into your short answer
because I love it is just a practical
thing I recommend if you're there right
now and you want to start a blog just
check out our guide to start a blog we
have so many people email us about
starting a blog so a lot of people find
us yeah comm slash blog like I was
looking how to start a blog and it came
across your website and now I listen to
your podcast or whatever so yeah the
minimalists comm slash blog ryan and i
couldn't even spell HTML eight years ago
and we figured out how to start a blog
and it's it was honestly the best
creative decision we ever did because it
led to everything else whether it was
the books or the tour
the podcast and everything else it all
started with starting a blog yeah I mean
my short answer really just kind of
speaks to what you had noted there you
know creates a create not to reach an
objective
don't let perfection be the enemy of
creation because right now that's where
Daisy's at she feels like her creations
aren't perfect and she's scared about
the feedback she's gonna get from her
imperfect creations but if you let
perfection stunt you well then you're
gonna spend your life stunted yes indeed
well if you get that feedback feedback
is great in fact early on we first
started creating we had comments on our
blog now people can comment on YouTube
or wherever look helpful criticism well
I say feedback that that's out that's
what feedback I'd only get criticism
from feedback criticism is the seagull
who flies over craps on everything flies
away so doesn't add value they so
helpful criticism you wouldn't even call
it helpful criticism you would you would
just call it feedback I call it feedback
because they provide a solution usually
it's not criticism illuminates the
problem feedback highlights the solution
between that Shawn yeah so in early on
you'll get the feedback you need to make
your writing better or your creations
better and that's a good thing
absolutely all right our next question
is from Matthew Matthew writes I'm
paralyzed by decision overload
I have viable options for careers but
it's hard to choose one and I don't want
to look back on missed opportunities
well here's my short answer for you
Matthew missing out is letting go in
advance and think about that for a
second sometimes we pick something up
because we don't want to miss out I've
got this quote opportunity in front of
me I'd be dumb not to do it but so I
pick it up I waste all my time on it and
then I am forced to let it go
a month from now two months from now six
months from now a year from now a decade
from now I've been dragging this
opportunity with me this whole time
but maybe he just miss out you get to
let go of that problem in advance now go
going back to his his problem while his
question here really
he said I'm paralyzed by decision over
right yeah I have viable options for
careers but it's hard to choose one and
thinking that we have some some some
options are our binary but most aren't
and so my second pithy answer for him is
binary thinking produces greyscale
rainbows sometimes you're missing out on
something and you're not you don't have
to fully miss out on it I mean I think
about my team of doctors who helps me
out one of them isn't a I mean he was on
the podcast Chris Kelly and he brought
doctor tell me wood on the podcast now
Chris is more informed than any doctor
that I've worked with and he's been more
helpful to me than any doctor I've
worked with but he is not a doctor he is
a computer scientist and he left that
world and started he's an autodidact he
just started learning all about his own
health problems cuz he had a lot of the
same health problems I had he started
fixing himself and he started working
with other doctors and he isn't a
medical doctor per se but he and the
folks the team at nourish balance thrive
have helped me with my medical problems
more than any medical doctor has so is
your objective becoming a medical doctor
or is it healing people because if it's
healing people maybe you're not missing
out on the opportunity of not becoming
the medical doctor maybe there are other
ways to help heal people absolutely I
mean my short answer is there are many
live oh my goodness and maybe we do that
there are many paths in life if you
choose one that aligns with your values
and beliefs you can't go wrong you know
I think about Mariah and I we love to go
to different restaurants I mean there's
just like an endless amount of
restaurants in LA and we love trying
just having new experiences with with
these different restaurants and we went
to one last night very nice place
Italian place and they had like this
menu that I could have just you know
close my eyes and pick something random
it probably would have been awesome huh
and it was this like decision overload
and Mariah and I are talking about we're
gonna get I'm like okay I'll get this
and then you get dad and we'll
we'll share we'll have a bite and okay
and you guys we're with the the folks
and bergamont uh Nathaniel and Gillian
are you guys get that and we'll have a
bite of yours and like you know we're
trying to pick everything as much as we
can right but like there's a point we're
like you know I've got to look at it and
say okay I can't get everything off this
menu I have to make a decision so what
do I need to consider with this decision
well we got to consider
Mariah's dietary restrictions got to
consider you know consider healthy
decisions if I ever want to go back to
that restaurant I can always go back
there right and try it again and if it
burns down you know yeah maybe I'll be a
little bit bummed out that I couldn't
try the rest of the menu but there are a
lot of other restaurants so I guess what
I'm trying to say here is that Matthew
you are gonna miss out on stuff in fact
once you make a decision you're missing
out a 99% of everything else but it
doesn't mean that this is your only path
the only time you choose a path yeah I
would just add one thing to that cuz I
agree with your pithy answer as long as
your values and beliefs are grounded in
morality right yeah yeah of course I
mean I think I think values I mean it's
to me I mean its values are always in
conjunction with morality I don't think
so and I mean we example we can have a
long esoteric conversation about that
okay
but Hitler valued certain so we're
talking about exceptions rather than the
rule right sutures well maybe but I
don't I'm killin right no no he's a he's
an exaggerated hyperbolic example to
illustrate the point there are many
people who value the wrong things mm
yeah I in my 20s my values I valued the
wrong things but even then like
sometimes you I mean I think I think
you're right like we need to be
deliberate with what our values are we
need but I wouldn't I can never look at
someone and say you were valuing the
wrong things I could say I can I could
say I can look at myself and say that
sure that's exactly where I'm going with
it I would never look at anyone else and
say you're valuing the wrong
thing I could say from my perspective I
would not value that because of XY and Z
but I would never criticize someone on
on what they own what they value as long
as long as it's not interfering with
other people's well-being right I mean
that's I mean and like I said I think
that kind of goes unsaid but I
understand what you're saying about we
can kind of get into an esoteric
conversation yes we have several more
questions about fear Ryan I reached out
to our patreon audience here and we have
a bunch of questions I know we won't be
able to answer all of them but I'm
really fascinated by some of these
questions so let me let me see what we
got here
here are my four favorites Cory asked
how do you know if it is fear holding
you back or if you were actually not
ready for example changing a career or
starting a business angel asked fear is
nearly always a factor when a big change
is in the works such as finally quitting
a job that doesn't align with your
values but pays the bills how do you
balance planning for the big change to
leave at the quote right time versus
taking the leap and the rich asked my
partner is changing jobs leaving a job
she hated hated and starting a new one
but it's not her dream job but she will
probably hate this new job less but she
would really love to start her own
business and open a shop but there is
fear of failure a lot of buts in this
this question here but there's feeling
of fear failure coupled with the
overwhelm of where to start any advice
to help the fear of really going for
what she wants and starting her own
business and the finally Benjamin asks I
was taught that I need to avoid conflict
and to put others before me
and keep everyone happy I was I was
taught to ignore everyone who wasn't in
the watchtower and tract society I fear
that if I speak up for myself it would
cause more issues than if I stay silent
what could I do to practice getting rid
of this fear that I know is something I
shouldn't be fearful of in the first
place so we have those questions and
possibly some others about fear and if
you'd like to hear our answers to those
questions then you
can listen to this week's PostScript
episode over at the minimalist private
podcast available exclusively to our
patreon supporters I'm gonna stop
reading from the script for a second
just say thank you if you are a patreon
supporter you help keep the lights on
quite literally yeah we have this light
on above us that you helped pay for but
also the studio space that we're in you
pay for joardyn or filmmaker podcast
Sean or podcast producer Ryan and I
don't make any money from the podcast at
all yet in fact we actually spend money
I'd eventually like to make money from
it so if you want to become a patreon
supporter we'd be really grateful and
because we're grateful we do a bunch of
extra stuff for our patreon supporters
that are its exclusive to you so every
week we have this thing that's called
the minimalist private podcast feed so
it shows up in your regular podcast
player say you listen to this on Apple
podcast or overcast or wherever you
listen to the podcast and you just get
this little RSS link and you put it in
it's your private own private link so we
do a separate podcast episode every
single week we also once a month we do
this live stream where we do a video
episode where answer your questions it's
called ask of the minimalists anything
and over the last year we've put fifteen
live events over on the minimalist
private podcast feed as well so if you
want to listen to our live events
whether it was in Dallas or Houston or
Alston or Philadelphia or Manhattan or a
bunch of others we had these wonderful
private podcast so Ryan did one with Cal
Newport well I was definitely ill for
the new board and Peter no Paul Johnson
Peter Johnson Paul Johnson yeah and so
we do a bunch of things for our patreon
supporters because we keep this podcast
a hundred percent advertisement free and
we could really use your help so if you
want to help us out head on over to the
minimalists comm slash support and you
can find ways to support us you could
become a patreon supporter and listen to
our extra episode every week you can
find all the details and good stuff over
there at the minimalists comm and here
is a snippet from this week's PostScript
episode
[Music]
you're never going to be completely
ready but you're going to be as ready as
you can be given the plans that you've
devised but eventually you're going to
have to take that leap even though
you're not gonna be ready it's going to
terrify you but you're going to have to
take the leap you know talking about
this private podcast man that one with
Cal and Paul well with with Canyon City
like that was that was also man like
just having him play live music like
that yeah that that alone you could just
you could just take out anything I had
to say and like just put in what Cal had
to say and can't in and you know Canyon
cities music like it would be that would
be worth the listen just that I can't
wait to get Cal Newport back on the
podcast he has a new book coming out I'm
not even gonna tell you about it yet but
it is oh my gosh
I wrote a blurb for it and he he he sent
me a message and said hey would you be
willing to write a blurb for this book
and I almost always say no to writing
blurbs I I said yes to two this year one
was for our our friend Paul Jarvis who
has a book coming out about I would just
called a minimalist business book yeah
and Cal Newports new book is about
technology and our relationship with
technology and the new technologies and
man he he just it's the best book I've
read this year and I can't wait to share
it with you as soon as he he releases
that book alright let's move on to the
added value portion of the show where we
talk about what's adding value to our
lives recently so our friend Andrew Bell
who probably has my favorite album of
the last decade of this decade which is
called black bear and then he his third
album came out last year we had him open
up for our Indianapolis event yeah and
he played some songs there it's called
dive deep well he just put out this it's
not acoustic but it's it's a hushed
version of that album live song he did
this he did that with black bear yeah
where he he had this like full you know
studio produced album and then came out
with this like simplified
version of not the whole album but of
different songs yeah I handful of songs
and it is so so good an attack agree if
we can let's take the title track from
that dive deep and we'll play the hushed
version at the end of this episode but
you've got to check it out mean and
Rubel it's it's minimalist music but
it's he does something with his voice as
an instrument his songwriting is like an
additional instrument it is truly
beautiful and yeah we're grateful that
he decided to do an event with us last
year but you gotta check out this album
it is called dive deep hushed it's just
an EP five songs yeah it's awesome
well since it's my birthday I can
recommend whatever I want and when I'm
recommending if you want to give me a
birthday present
go to the minimalists dot-com slash what
is it Josh Dayton slash Dayton and you
can find out how you can donate to this
food co-op that Josh and I are trying to
build the west side of Dayton is one of
the largest food deserts in the country
it's about a hundred thousand people
there who have access to fast food they
have access to 7-eleven food but they do
not have access to a grocery store like
you cannot go buy a head of lettuce in
West Dayton yeah it is a it's a crisis
it really is and Josh and I are trying
to do something about that if you can't
afford to donate a buck that's totally
cool then donate to now that's right
donate a quarter no if you can't afford
to donate a dollar you know it would
really help me out and help us out it
would most importantly help Dayton out
just share it with your friends and
family tweet about it or something just
just help us get to that number we're
trying to get a hundred thousand bucks
and when we do we can really make a huge
difference in West Dayton yeah so it's
our hometown and it is it has become you
know like you said one of the largest
food deserts in the country it's a
second hungriest city for families in
the entire country so forty percent of
the city lives on the west side of
dayton they did not have a single
grocery store and you can help us change
that this isn't somewhere far off
somewhere in the world this is this is
quite literally in our backyard you know
Ryan and I spent our first 31 years
there in Ohio and we want to help give
back yeah we want to contribute in a way
and you can help us contribute Ryan and
I are donating $25,000
own money and we need your help too to
get the rest of the money to get to
$100,000 there is also this logic album
that just came out I don't think you're
not you're not a huge fan a lot of young
Sinatra for yes it is so it's not why s
1v that I was like he said why said ya
junk Sinatra for it's like this it's a
serious he's had a while so good I
really enjoyed it he's what's cool about
logic is he's got this amazing way of
like telling a story with his with his
music but like he's telling us it's
almost a music well like it's like a rap
musical I feel like yeah I agree with
that and especially his previous albums
this one he really returned to that sort
of boom bap from the nine girly to mid
90s I think I chilled introduction it
was it was really good oh yeah I
definitely enjoyed it so yeah if you
want to enjoy that on Ryan's birthday as
well and then of course the minimalists
calm slash Dayton if you want to
contribute to the food co-op all right
let's move on to right here right now so
we talk about what's going on in the
lives of the minimalists right before
this we did behind the scenes live on
YouTube so usually on Tuesdays we record
a quick like live behind the scenes
behind the podcast and I just bring it
up cuz we got to talk about Ella my
five-year-old who's in kindergarten now
she dealt with her first bully oh yeah
and I'm not gonna talk about it here on
the podcast if you if you want to if you
won't want to listen to it but Backson I
had totally different parental advice
and we finally met in the middle but I
was shocked by her parental advice
because Ella has this bully in the house
or in the school and who like goes up
and hits her every day and calls her
sour face and then he hits her and I'm
like well of course you've got a heading
back and apparently I learned from
Rebecca that might not be the best
advice yeah but I also thought just
going to tell a teacher immediately
wasn't the best advice so we came up
with a strategy that we helped out with
so if you want to check that out go to
behind the scenes live over on our
YouTube channel also we've been doing
screen 'less saturdays yeah
great what do you what do you think so
far you any lessons learned well you
know it's funny the first screen lists
Saturday Mariah and I were playing we
were playing some board games like we
went to the Russian bathhouse and then
we you know got home we went out and
grab something to eat so it was probably
about maybe five six o'clock when we
were home and had to find something to
do you know besides read to each other
or I mean which we did we did do that
before we went to the bath house we were
reading an awesome book atomic habits by
James Keller he'll be on the he'll be on
the show later this year actually it's
I'm really looking forward to that
interview but but uh we're sitting there
playing this board game and I'm like I
really wish we had some music right now
but you know the music's on my phone
that's the only place I have my phone
and I just looked at my Ryan I'm like
this is a great experiment I'm really
glad that we're finding things out about
you know our screen usage but you know
we we made the decision like if we want
to listen to music like we're not I'm
not gonna have a bad time just for the
sake of of an experiment but that's why
we do these experiments is to really
find out what adds value to our lives so
I remember we were over watching the
third installment of the matrix not too
long ago and I was I was telling this to
he would pecs and I was talking about
how we were gonna go on Sunday we had to
go to where the heck did we go no it was
Saturday so Sunday's when we were
mountain mountain biking Saturday we
went we just met a friend over in Santa
Monica uh-oh it was like a it was like a
you yo it was like a yoga sound bath
have you ever done a sound bath
yeah dude I love a man like they're like
not it's not for me yeah dude it's like
you yeah you wouldn't be able to let go
enough man like you've really gotta let
go of like you have to suspend oh I can
let so much disbelief yeah I don't have
a belief you have to also pick up
another belief yeah I would I would
argue that you have to be able to lose
yourself and I could see where you would
not be able to lose yourself in a sound
bath right yeah because it's that cuz
there's a lot of it's very easy to judge
a sound bath well yeah yeah yeah so so
we went we went with did the sound bath
and then I'm like and then I gotta get
from this sound bath back to Tony's and
want to print out and then I gotta get
home like I don't want to print out all
these directions yeah I'm like I'm like
I'm definitely gonna use my phone for
maps so I can so I can you know get find
my way home like I'm not gonna I'm not
gonna be broman LA at midnight you know
trying to find my way back and you were
like would it be so bad if you got lost
Ryan and I was like you know what like
that is that's a good approach like at
least I'm gonna give it a shot and if I
do get lost not not the end of the world
out you know Mariah brought a phone in
case of an emergency right so you know
we could always go to it if we if we had
to dude it was great man cuz like when
you we did print out MapQuest no Google
Map Quest still think probably is we
printed Google Maps directions
getting to the the yoga works in Santa
Monica or wherever it was and getting
there it's funny how I forgot about when
you print out directions you are
cataloging the route like you are like
I'm making mental notes
okay 101 South 10 West four of learning
for the 405 North yeah dude it's like
and I'm cataloging this cuz I gotta get
home and I'm like okay as long as I get
to four or five I know from the 45 I get
to the 10 from the 10 I get to the 101
it's like and it and it's just like and
it was really easy because if something
wasn't someone else telling you what to
do you were had to figure it out
yourself
so it's like we had directions to to
yoga works when I got there I explained
to Tony I'm like dude I need to follow
you back to your house because I don't
know how to go and he's like oh no it's
real easy he just gave me like a couple
turns yeah I'm like and I went my
biggest fear was like kids in Los
Angeles I use Waze so much and it never
takes you the same way it it will you
know bypass as much traffic as possible
they mean it doesn't take you the same
ways so I was really worried about you
know wasting cuz dude if you get on the
highway at the wrong time you're done
yeah you you are better off like just
taking Santa Monica all the way to the
beach rather than trying
get on the highway sometimes that's the
best route yeah right so I was really
hot elliptic on the 405 sometimes yeah
dude so I was like worried about wasting
you know an hour or two hours and it
turns out really didn't waste so much
time I mean this is anecdotal it's
largely not that big of a difference no
matter what right yeah you might you
might waste an extra 20 minutes yeah but
if you plan accordingly oh by the way
because it's green the Saturday we kind
of don't have like I need to be
somewhere right now exactly and the
thing I've learned from this whole
experiment its permission to like get
lost - get lost yeah absolutely and by
the way that that temporary deprivation
yeah like I will go without you know we
went without music or whatever like like
I will go without it temporarily to
realize it also helps me realize how
much I do get value from that the other
six days a week yeah and you not be able
to get on my computer and look up
something on Google or check the
dictionary definition of the word yeah I
had that a couple times Rose like I want
to look at this word and then you have
like look it up tomorrow
right and I'll write stuff down and and
and the learning of the directions like
I remember when I when she moved to st.
Petersburg Florida back in 2008 right
before she found out she had stage 4
lung cancer I spent a lot of time with
her down in Florida that year she was
going through all the chemo and
radiation
but it was before the maps were
ubiquitous on the phone or I had a map
on my blackberry but it didn't work well
we've got you long view proximity yeah
you're approximately here I'm like I'm
not even there right now right um yeah
half a mile from there but yeah and so
just it wasn't very useful and so I'm
printing out the directions and also I
was taking my mom to all these different
appointments for her chemo radiation
doctor's visits etc and as I was going
through that I really learned the city I
fell in love with st. Petersburg because
I learned the city I knew how to get
around and even now every time we go
back because we have a coffee shop there
now I don't need maps to get around the
city because I know how to go from A to
B to Z because I've gone through it so
many times you learn those patterns same
with Dayton Ohio saying with Missoula we
live there
and and I go to other cities though and
I'm like I need this machine to tell me
what to do well it's weird because we
ask the question what do we do
for maps like how do we get around and
it's like they're actually disempowering
yeah they're so disempowering and I
honestly like it it makes you fearful of
like learning something new mmm-hmm but
the the ease of learning was shocking to
me I didn't realize how dude I know just
from that one Saturday I could tell you
exact time of the 10:00 I could tell you
how to get almost anywhere with those
three highways and I know yeah just from
that one experience but the thought of
it before it happened I was like there's
no way I'm gonna be able to learn all
this in one day but it's like if you
force yourself you deprive yourself a
little bit it kind of forces forces uh
creation I guess in a way I think the
lesson is if you want to overcome fear
get lost a little bit yeah man all right
what else we going what else is going on
right now we've got a new on our website
we have some new essays there's this
clean surfaces essay that's two rules
that I've implemented Beck's and I have
implemented in our home about these two
rules of having clear surfaces and
having fewer surfaces in the house and
we talked about why there I'll put a
link to that in the show notes there's a
few new essays on there on the website
as well also my mom died nine years ago
this month and you know it was I learned
a lot from that whole experience and
it's it was the it was a starting point
really for the minimalist was her
passing I wrote a long essay about it
called dealing with the death of a loved
one
I wrote that a few years ago but it's if
you're going through that or if you you
know someone in your family who has died
recently or if you're going through it
right now I send this to people all the
time who were reaching out for with
questions about you know my father's in
hospice or my grandmother has you know
gone to a nursing home and she doesn't
have much longer this this is what I
learned from that so it's called dealing
with the death of a loved one we'll put
a link to that in the show notes as well
we've got a few videos up on our website
as well you aren't entitled to anything
and how to stop compulsive consumption
these are quickie episodes of the
minimalist podcast and also our Today
Show interview interview aired so you
want to check out our newest Today Show
interview you can go over to our I
should just go to the the show notes
page the minimalists comm slash podcast
and we'll put a link to the Today Show
enter interview and the show notes if
you want to comment on this episode you
can do so over at youtube.com slash the
minimalists also on youtube right now we
do quickie episodes of the minimalist
podcast if you want little short morsels
three to twenty minutes long versions of
the minimalist podcast then you can
check those out over our youtube channel
also living room conversations every
wednesday we put out a living room
conversation either from Ryan's living
room my living room we answer one
question little bite-sized conversations
about minimalism also we're gonna do a
house tour soon over on our YouTube
channel so subscribe if you want you can
find all the podcast show notes on our
website but if you want them to show up
right there and your email inbox head on
over to the minimalists com
put your email address at the top
subscribe to our e-mail newsletter there
we'll send you any any of the new show
notes that come out also any new
writings from the minimalist but no spam
ever Ryan you got anything else for us
yeah man I got some voicemail comments
and tips from our listeners check them
out a minimalist this is Morgan O'Brien
from Avis California my husband and I
recently lost her job in Seattle heist
the Pacific Crest Trail and are now
deciding on a new place to live and work
we've narrowed our search to two cities
and are now waiting to hear back from
companies we hope to work out through
all this we could discuss what we want
in the city and recently we listened to
the cities podcast we came up with a
comparison process I thought would be
worthwhile to share first let's not
watching value in the location for us
these are things like walkability
restaurants coffee shops mouthful food
stores
Vince access and overall need for a cup
because we hope to go carve then we list
our values we listed our values in
priorities in life for us these are
health family friends and community
contribution then we made a financial
slash job focused section where we
compared job paid relative cost of
living the contribution of that work to
our community and
work culture we made a matrix in Excel
for each comparing the location and job
separately
what this allows us to do is look at
each place more objectively and consider
all aspects of our lives in that
location we found we had a strong
emotional connection to one of the two
cities it has allowed us to open our
minds to the other great options that
also aligns with our values and we may
have even found that it might be a
better fit for us
I hope this helps others in our
situation hi this is Kara in California
and I was just listening to your
donating podcast and I wanted to address
the question about donating or tossing
keyboards or games or puzzles with
missing pieces and I'm an elementary
teacher and I know for a fact that many
of our lower grade teachers keep games
in their classroom and they're
constantly looking for broken ordains
and pieces at places such as the good
well because kindergarteners tend to
leave those pieces so anytime they can
find a game and combine pieces and turn
it into one game with lots of extra
pieces so that way it's okay to lose the
pieces they are more than happy to
forget those things as well and I just
thought that would be a helpful thing to
know that it really actually isn't trash
to everybody you can donate such things
hi guys this is Jared from Seattle real
quick one of the three quick tips and
suggestions I think that some people
don't think of when getting rid of stuff
um three suggestions one you could
actually sell your unused clothes and
make money there's a place up here in
Seattle called crossroads they're also
out in LA but they actually give you I
think 35 percent of the sale price or
they give you a credit you know higher
amount of money back to shop the store
so that's the way we found my wife and I
found we're not using stuff to go
actually sell our clothes to there's a
place called twice old books out here we
actually could sell your use books as
well and actually print some money I had
a ton of books highlighted Galliard
reason never wound up actually selling
I'm started reading them so I decide to
sell back me some decent money the last
one is you know you don't need to get I
have favorite boots boots are expensive
quality boots are expensive if you spend
anywhere from $300 on up so I just took
them to get resold and they're great I
thought it was going to need the whole
bottom I just need to get the heel
redone was like 45 bucks so anyway three
quick tips that I thought might work to
save money and actually make money on
the sidewalk all right Joe that's it for
this episode if you have a question for
the minimalist give us a call for zero
six two one nine seven eight three nine
you can also email a voice memo to
podcast at the minimalists calm and if
you leave here with just one message we
hope it's this love people and use
things because the opposite never works
thanks for listen yeah we'll see you
next time
alright oh by the way let's so let's
play you out with with the sound bath
just kidding
what you have with dive deep hushed by
our friend Andrew Bell unless you're
listening to this on youtube then I'm
sure there'll be a link to a video or
something but if you listen to the audio
version enjoy dive deep hushed by Andrew
Bell
and minimus